IF IT'S JUNK, THROWN AWAY OR
GIVE IT TO WHO NEEDS IT.
>> Jesse: I'M GOING TO GET
THEM TICKETS TO THE MAT.
DANA, I AM JUDGING THESE
PARENTS, JUDGING THEM HARSHLY.
JUDGE COMEY WOULD PROBABLY AGREE
LEGAL YOU CAN CHARGE THE PARENTS
WITH CHILD ABUSE.
THEY'RE EITHER CHEAP OR LIBERAL.
THE WHOLE POINT OF CHRISTMAS
MORNING IS THE PHYSICAL
UNWRAPPING OF THE GIFTS.
IT'S THE RIPPING OF THE WRAPPING
PAPER, SURPRISE ON THEIR FACES,
CREATION OF PILES.
THAT'S THE EXPERIENCE.
YOU DON'T WANT TO GET AN
EXPERIENCE.
YOU WANT TO EXPERIENCE THE
UNWRAPPING A PHYSICAL GIFT.
ANY PARENT THAT DOESN'T
UNDERSTAND THAT IS STUPID.
WE ARE GOING TO BRING THEM UP ON
SERIOUS CHARGES.
>> Jessica: WHAT ABOUT
UNWRAPPING A TIE, LIKE THIS
BEAUTY.
>> Jesse: THIS WAS THE GIFT
EXCHANGE, THE TAPING OF THE
"THE FIVE" SPECIAL.
IT'S A GUTFELD TIE.
HOPEFULLY I'M NOT ADDING TO HIS
BANK ACCOUNT BY HAVING THIS.
I WEAR IT PROUDLY AND IT LOOKS
GOOD.
THE PRIME TIME ONE, WE ARE
WORKING ON THAT.
>> Jessica: JUDGE, WHAT ARE
YOU GETTING YOUR GRANDSON?
>> Judge Jeanine: EVERY MEMBER
CHRISTMAS EVE AS BEING THE WORST
NIGHT OF THE YEAR.
YOU KNOW WHY?
AFTER THE KIDS WENT TO BED.
I DID ALL THE COOKING, THAT'S
TRUE.
THE KIDS WENT TO BED WE HAD PUT
TOGETHER THE GAMES, THE TRAIN,
WHATEVER.
ALL NIGHT LONG.
WE COULD PUT IT IN FRONT OF THE
CHRISTMAS TREE IN THE MORNING.
SOMETIMES I THINK THAT WE BUY
THINGS FOR KIDS THAT ARE SO
OVER-THE-TOP AND SO RIDICULOUS.
IT'S ALMOST ABOUT SELF GUILT.
LIKE WE ARE NOT AS GOOD A PARENT
IF WE DON'T SPEND THAT MUCH
MONEY.
I KIND OF LOOK AT THIS A
DIFFERENT WAY.
I KIND OF LOOK AT IT AS, MAYBE
WE HAVE OVER DONE SOME STUFF.
MAYBE A LITTLE EDUCATIONAL
STUFF.
MAYBE THIS, THAT, OBVIOUSLY PUT
THE BOXES IN THE MIDDLE OF IT.
KIDS ARE HAPPY.
MY GRANDSON WILL PROBABLY GET A
POT OUT OF THE CABINET AND
PLAYING WITH IT.
I GOT THEM ALL KINDS OF THINGS.
>> Jesse: THAT'S TRUE, YOU CAN
SPEND HUNDREDS OF DOLLARS ON
THESE EXPENSIVE GIFTS AND THEN
YOU GIVE THE KID A STICK OR A
BALL FOR $2 AND THEY LOVE IT.
>> Tom: THAT'S ALL YOU NEED.
MY PARENTS WERE A LOT MORE HARSH
THAN THESE ONES.
THIS WOMAN WHO WROTE THE ARTICLE
SAID THEY TAKE THE KIDS SKIING
TO BIG BEAR OR GO TO
DISNEY WORLD.
WE DIDN'T HAVE DISNEY WORLD.
I WOULD BEG TO GO TO
DISNEY WORLD.
MY DAD WOULD SAY LOOK AT THE
VIEWMASTER.
LOOK AT THE PICTURES OF DISNEY.
THAT'S ALL AHEAD AS A KID.
I USED TO GIVE MY KIDS, THE BEST
GIFT, WHENEVER I WAS ON THE
ROAD, MY HOTEL KEYS.
I WOULD GIVE THEM EACH, I WOULD
SAY HERE'S A CREDIT CARD AND
THEY WOULD PLAY WITH THE
CREDIT CARD.
THEY WOULD PRETEND THEY WERE
HAVE A STORY.
>> Dana: YOU'RE AT THE FRONT
DESK CHECKING IN, YOU WOULD SAY
"I NEED TWO KEYS."
>> Tom: I WOULD WALK OUT WITH
THE KEYS AND JUST GIVE THEM TO
MY KIDS.
WHEN I WAS A KID, MY TEACHER IN
SECOND GRADE SAID YOU CAN BRING
IN FOR SHOW AND TELL ONE GIFT
BUT ONLY ONE GIFT AT ALL THE
KIDS WERE LIKE "ONLY ONE